-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The House January 6th committee
voted unanimously today
to subpoena
former President Trump.
I would say this is big news,
but it's really more like
putting one more parking ticket
on that van that's been
on your block for a year.
That ticket ain't getting paid.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
when former President Trump
received a subpoena
earlier this year
for any classified documents
taken from the White House,
he told an employee to move
boxes to his personal residence.
Man, he is a bad criminal.
You're supposed to get rid
of the evidence.
Trump is the first criminal to
plant the evidence on himself.
[ Laughter ]
"This weed?
No, I'm not holding this
for a friend."
[ Laughter ]
"I bought this with my money!"
A jury in Connecticut yesterday
ordered conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones to pay nearly $1 billion
to the families affected by
the Sandy Hook shooting.
So, I hope he got paid
really well for his work
as the Mucinex guy.
[ Laughter ]
The FDA announced yesterday
that it has authorized
the omicron targeted coronavirus
vaccine booster shots
for children as young
as five years old.
Which is great news if you're
a parent of young children
or think that you might be.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Producers for Lebron James'
talk show "The Shop"
announced yesterday that they
will not air an upcoming episode
with Kanye West due to his use
of hate speech.
Because once they
edited it all out,
this is what
they were left with.
-So...
[ Laughter ]
And...
-That wasn't that bad.
That wasn't that offensive.
[ Applause ]
A few edits, and that was just
I think
what all of us are thinking.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Idaho recently broke
a Guinness World Record
for longest duration balancing
a guitar on his chin.
Even more amazing, he managed to
keep it on there the entire time
he was being kicked out
of the party.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meta...
Meta this week launched
its most advanced
virtual reality headset ever,
which costs $1,500.
They're so advanced,
you'll completely forget
that your wife left you.
[ Laughter ]
The car company Rezvani has
announced a new $250,000 SUV
called the Vengeance, which has
options for body armor,
explosive protection,
and night vision.
So come hell or high water,
your kids will get to soccer!
[ Laughter ]
Today was National No Bra Day.
So, looks like
Biden hasn't undone
ALL of Trump's executive orders.
[ Laughter ]
Dunkin' Donuts recently changed
its customer loyalty program
from DD Perks
to Dunkin' Rewards,
and I can only assume
it's because they were sued
by a 1980s porn star.
[ Laughter ]
"Happy No Bra Day, Dee Dee!"
And finally, the Social Security
Administration announced today
that recipients will receive
a cost of living adjustment
next year of 8.7%.
So, get ready for that
to trickle down
to your $5 birthday checks!
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.